- My name's Brian Johnsrud,
and I manage the Arts,
Humanities, and Social Science
curriculum here at Khan Academy.
So I was the first person in
my family to attend college
and I remember my freshman year
the first course I was taking
was in literature and history
and we were reading a primary source
and it was talking about
the Norman Invasion in 1066
and I remember reading,
the Normans took a boat
from France to England
and I remember thinking,
why would they take a boat,
why wouldn't they just walk?
And so I went home, and I
opened a map, and I realized,
on my gosh, because England's
an island, and I had just...
My history education was
so subpar in high school
here I was, a first
generation college student,
in a class my freshman year,
thinking, I don't belong here,
I don't even know that
England is an island.
So I had two choices in front of me,
I could have quit and acknowledged
that I don't belong here,
I shouldn't be in this course,
or, I could ask for help
at least 10 times a day,
which is what I did.
I went to office hours, I
got help from the librarians
who gave me extra books to read
and recommended books on course, and...
I mean, really, I was craving
a resource like Khan Academy
because I knew I had these gaps
and I needed someone to help me fill them.
I really struggled with my writing
and so I was at the writing center
almost every day in college
recognizing that I needed to get better
and I could just avoid
writing or avoid those courses
or say, I know this is going to be hard
and the way that I'm gonna get through it
is by asking for help by
admitting my own humility,
and knowing what I don't know
and just signing myself
up for the struggle.